[Musique]
new d'où vous vient votre nom c'est
coluche qui me l'a donnée puis voilà
peut-être à l'époque du café théâtre
est ce que vous aviez envie de retourner
de rejouer au café enfin maintenant vous
êtes quand même un petit peu devenu un
objet à partir du moment où vous êtes
une vedette vous avez une valeur
marchande
le café-théâtre s'avoue valoriserait
s'avoue dévaloriserait si je suis je
commence à raisonner comme ça je peux
rien non je vais je sais pas je crois
pas dans le contexte du café-théâtre
peut-être ça apportera du monde ne s'est
pas la même chose toute façon ne s'est
pas du théâtre c'est du café théâtre
c'était toute une équipe c'est pas c'est
pas moi dans un numéro spécial c'est
l'amitié qui parle quand vous pensez au
café théâtre où c'est ce qu'on dit non
c'est ce qu'on y joue oui parce que
l'amitié veut dire je crois que le café
théâtre est la chose la plus dure dans
les rapports affectifs
de toute façon c'est un peu une jungle
voiture mais c'est très bien c'est très
très bien alors c'est pas c'est pas
l'amitié ça me joins que j'ai d'être sur
scène et puis d'avoir un contact avec
les gens tout de suite d'avoir une
réponse sur tous les médias est-ce que
c'est plus difficile pour une femme
d'être comique pour un homme d'être
comique
oui
je pense oui toute façon tout est plus
difficile pour une femme
j'ai encore faire taxer tout est plus
difficile
oui monsieur aux faux parce qu'on est
toujours charmant diverses et c'est
toujours des axes des adjectifs de
choses pas voulu c'est à dire que quand
moi je lis que je suis charmante où je
suis
mignonne où je suis bamba c'est ce n'est
pas merci mais ce n'est pas volontaire
bien c'est pas moi qui me suis fait je
me suis pas c'est pas quelque chose de
volontaire d'un homme on dit pas il est
mignon il est charmant il est gracieux
il est il pétille jamais jamais en
disant c'est toujours un grand acteur ou
un acteur ou une composition quelque
chose comme ça alors d'une fille il faut
faire oublier son sens physique enfin
faire mieux je suis ravi d'être comme ça
est-ce que cela vous gêne de tourner des
scènes vous devez totalement nue sache
mardi à poser cette question je sais pas
je ne sais pas ce qu'on la pose assez
souvent oui alors qu'est ce que je vais
dire oui bien sûr alors là la personne
qui a posé cette question qui est un
acteur dit que ça ne vous gêne pas du
tout qui s'appelle bernard menez vous
avez tourné tous les deux une scène nue
lui dise ah oui avec dégonfler la fia
[Musique]